[Music]
saying goodbye to this character this
incredibly beloved character yeah
is that Tuffy it's tough in some
respects but it's also really nice and
it's kind of bittersweet I guess you've
been playing this character for a few
years
whatever it's been four and a half years
whatever you're quite happy to say
goodbye because you know it's nice to
you know put that aside and move on are
you doing scenes with minimal clothing
on yeah the top
what kind of prep did you do yeah you
know leading up to this on so much
better shape in those movies and I am
you know in daily life and you you put
the work in to get there know if they
say right we're ready for you on set
okay bring it on you know this and then
suddenly they're not over just have to
wait for a light to thank you
so you're there when you know you're
about to be shown on camera like if you
talk about so that's a guy of course
you're gonna jump down like through some
prep and press ups or whatever because
if you look at who and you do your bed
you get a little pop off yeah that's
just yeah there's a couple of scenes
where I managed to talk myself and into
some clothing because I just sometimes
just isn't isn't necessary you got some
pole now yeah through the films there's
been quite a strong movement to see
anymore you know the fit you managed to
make it through all three without kind
of going there what was it what's your
reaction to them and everybody asking
for even more of you you know I don't
know like well I know I don't have to
say about that you know I don't think
you need to see you know that part of me
or that part of Dakota really you know I
just become sort of creature this if we
don't need it
[Music]